hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
there's an interesting little battle
heating up this holiday season I say
little because it's maybe not the most
important of all the sales in terms of
volume but it's definitely worth looking
at it's the Battle of the low cost pure
Android smartphones this time around
it's the Nexus 5 for 350 bucks 16 gigs
off contract black or white or the Moto
X 350 bucks
16 gigs off contract in any color
customized this is a cyber monday sale
and it's one of many Cyber Monday and
Black Friday sales I'll be tweeting out
on Twitter so if you want to follow me
there to check out those that's where
I'll be sharing them all but at this
point for that price which way do you go
all right so if you want the full
breakdown of all the pros and cons of
each of these smartphones and what's
like to basically use one or the other
as your daily driver of my full review -
both of them right provide a like button
so there will be a link to a video you
can check out to get a better sense of
what it's actually like to use each of
the phones but to break things down and
sort of make it simpler the pros and
cons list - each of these devices is
actually remarkably similar on the pro
side both of these are really nice
devices to hold in the hand or a nice
size but hands-down the better feeling
device and better ergonomics device goes
to the Moto X this is just an area where
Motorola spent a ton of time and energy
in design to figure out exactly how they
should make a device curved like this
and has some really interesting curves
they look cool it looks cool on a table
it feels good in the hand when you're
holding it I'm holding up your face to
make a call all types of different usage
scenarios just feels better holding the
Moto X and it's also a bit more compact
the bezels are so small that if you're
moving from something like an iPhone
this only feels a tiny bit bigger than
the iPhone which could make it a first
time recommendation for a lot of people
moving from an iPhone to an Android
phone for the first time this is
definitely the form factor that I would
recommend now I happen to be a huge fan
of the Stormtrooper Nexus 5 maybe that's
just me but there is also the
customization factor that again puts the
Moto X ahead you can go through moto
maker and apparently with this Black
Friday deal you'll be able to get a
totally customized Moto X for $350 so
the Nexus 5 is we already know only
comes in black or white and I've made a
video just comparing the designs of
these two maybe that's not a bad thing
at all
you can go with black or white if you
want but with the Nexus 5 you can pick
from a whole range of a rainbow of
different colors of the different backs
different accent colors the different
fronts and the custom accessory isn't
even an engraving on the back and the
best part of this actually is is if you
order a Moto X and a Nexus 5 today
you'll get the custom Moto X first
that's how much it's not delaying a
shipping process at all the Nexus 5 has
advantages on paper in the hardware or
physical specs department so you're
going to get much better numbers on
paper with the Nexus 5 basically what
I'm saying here is you get a quad-core
Snapdragon 800 processor in here which
is way more powerful than on the Moto X
and you also getting much bigger
brighter 5-inch 1080p display which is
much brighter and much higher resolution
and bigger than the Moto X so you're
going to get higher end specs if you
choose to go with the Nexus 5 and it
also gives you a slightly bigger chassis
it's just a tiny bit thicker and overall
a little bit taller and wider and it's a
bigger device to use which brings us to
the battery conveniently one of the
biggest cons to both the Nexus 5 and the
Moto X is the battery now if you just
look at the pier number is a slightly
bigger chassis on the Nexus 5 we'll give
it a bigger battery 2300 milliamp hours
while the Moto X will give you a two
thousand two hundred million power
battery now if you stop right there you
might think oh the battery life will be
pretty similar nothing too big to worry
about here but if you keep looking
further deeper into it you'll see the
Nexus 5 has a much larger much brighter
higher resolution display it has very
different specs on the inside and a big
part of it is the Moto X has an AMOLED
display and an active notification
system takes big advantage in that and
you get the Moto X eight chip in that
computing system as I talked about in
the full review takes again a whole
bunch of more physical optimization into
the battery life so you're going to get
substantially better battery life on the
Moto X then you are on the Nexus 5 now
the numbers in the full review will give
you a better idea of whether or not you
can deal with the battery life for the
Nexus 5 but I actually went ahead and
picked up the wireless charger from the
Google Play Store the official one which
has a magnet in the back that helps I
guess ease my range anxiety and lets me
charge in way more places but not
everyone is going to be will
to spend the 50 bucks to go ahead and do
that anyway another thing on the con
side of both of these devices is the
cameras on the backs both of them
comparatively speaking have weaker
cameras but actually since my review
video of the Moto X it's gotten a pretty
substantial update to the camera
software and it actually moved the
camera app to the Google Play Store so
now they can continually update that
quickly and timely and with plenty of
updates through the Play Store which is
really nice so everyone's Moto X will
have the updated camera software but
essentially the big difference here is
going to be between the speed and the
quality of the camera versus the Nexus 5
and the Moto X the speed is way better
on the Moto X camera you can take faster
shots the delay and time between when
you tap to take a picture and actually
take the picture is way smaller you have
faster shutter speeds it's just an
overall faster camera on the Moto X in
terms of quality the quality Department
is going to go to the Nexus 5 it's going
to take better photos and videos in
terms of quality especially video it's
still passable quality on the Moto X
camera right now it's not miserable or
anything anymore but it's definitely you
know when you compare it to other more
expensive six $700 devices both of these
you will see have obviously made a trade
off to save on price and that shows
other than that Google and Motorola are
technically one of the same basically as
a company right now so the actual
experience of using these two devices is
going to be very similar but since the
Nexus is a nexus and it's the actual
flagship for Androids newest version and
the Moto X is just a quick half-step
behind but it's getting very quick
updates right now you're going to have a
couple of software advantages to using a
nexus 5 they both like I said have
Android 4.4 KitKat but you can have some
things like the exclusive google
experience launcher you're going to have
you know a slightly better performance
overall in terms of smoothness on the
Nexus 5 for sure and you'll be first in
line for Android 4.4.1
or whatever the next version of Android
is I'm sure you'll get it first on a
nexus if you're into that so bottom line
when you're weighing the pros and cons
it's up to you and well let me know in
the comments section below which one you
would rather pick up this holiday season
for that $350 price tag I kind of
already made my decision
I still love rock
many motox to people because it's a
great great first Android phone for sure
it's also going to come down to
availability because well this is only
sold in the Google Play Store and in the
areas where you can buy things from
Google Play whereas the Moto X is
supported in way more areas and on an
additional carrier there's a Verizon
version so that's a thing but yeah
there's definitely differences and
similarities that you're going to want a
way to make your decision either way
this Black Friday and Cyber Monday and
all the days in between I'm going to be
tweeting out the the best deals
essentially that I find all over the
internet in tech so if you want to see
that stuff camera gear video gear
smartphones tablets TVs basically
anything that I find be sure to follow
me on Twitter I'll have a link right
below it's at mkbhd check that out also
I'm wearing an overworked shirt right
now because his new EP dropped today
that will be linked below check that out
the description below is basically a
goldmine right now
either way I'm done thanks for watching
this video comparison and I will talk to
you guys in the next one Happy Holidays
peace